[Music]
in no hablo English news
not Daniel speak English submitted by at
work in Yoshi as my childhood never seen
a frog twerk before
Yoshi's not a frog a dinosaur isn't it
yeah it was a dinosaur it's a frog it's
a frog Dino what is this
I was [ __ ] with people so hard and
not like I put it up on my story one
time I think I said it was either a frog
or a frog or a turtle oh I say it's a
turtle and everyone freaked out best
thing ever
what is it they almost gave me a heart
it all makes sense don't question it
yeah a Taco Bell employee was fired for
refusing to serve an english-speaking
customer the tables have turned
we're taking over baby wait what
english-speaking customer and they're
like no is it because rude as I thought
it was because they're like from Britain
and then we're in America and they're
like that English is not that good
burrito oh but if you the title of the
news with the headline it's the Spanish
Spanish and Taco Bell employee refused
to serve an english-speaking customers
in Mexico in Miami oh I am I am eco damn
what do they say learn to speak Spanish
in English English learn no English of
butoh no she wasn't rude she was pretty
polite it was just the fact that she was
saying like she was in speak English
which is like dude you should if you're
working ok she get a job at Taco Bell if
you don't speak English I know it's like
the midnight hour
oh is this exact 10:30 p.m. so it's not
that no it's not that
but is it like a neighborhood words 99
Hispanic or whatever the the 2010 census
said that it was 89
of residents speak Spanish as their
first or second language in more than 94
94 percent identify as Hispanic or
Latino oh yeah what about all the like
Chicano borns did it have Chicanos over
there laymen they're born like they're
Hispanic well they're probably Cuban or
Dominica yeah like what they don't speak
the Spanish or like 94% identified and
in the 89 percent speak it oh that's a
high percentage that is huge so let me
show you guys the video that the
customer so you can't take my order
you won't understand what I'm saying but
you speak something like I have a car in
the back there's no English cuz I wanna
order you tell me I wish I could be they
phone cuz I wanna understand the
conversation
people that show up America y'all take
over the whole population okay
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know the menu she won't
understand what I'm saying
yeah she's asking like you don't
understand the menu and then wait can't
you can't you just say that no combo
yeah and this picture me on num num
number six maybe she was just fed up
whatever [ __ ] was that's recorded
halfway yeah so maybe at that point
she's just like [ __ ] it I don't speak
English you know and it's like I just
don't think both sides are really trying
to work it out cuz I they were I feel
like if I can order food and France
that's not out of chain and they can get
what the hell like yeah are you sir are
you sure aids in other countries I'm
just [ __ ] write notes I'll be [ __ ]
doing this like hey you know cake yeah
honestly I feel like the employee yeah
is the main one that's at fault because
what I'm assuming is that when this
customer was at the box like trying to
speak to her she was probably like no no
no no no cuz that's why she never even
took the orders so she would have to go
up to the window at this lady the lady
was just stubborn as hell like she could
have figured it out yeah so Taco Bell
did announce that she no longer works
oh yeah she needed that paycheck though
but then that manager also sucks if they
really didn't know how to speak English
because why is he hiring employees that
can't even the manager was like confused
too like you don't know how to read the
order who's like wait what you don't
even know the menu yes that lady said
like I'm speaking this year do you know
the menu what the hell is weird I don't
know just talking about some like
franchises yes okay yeah that's crazy so
that means there's places in the US
where you could work at a fast food
place and not even have to stop how is
that crazy to you go to this six
two-six bro but it's not fast food it's
ethnic food oh so what to a hell of
Chinese play you can expect that pretty
much yeah yeah but then like if it's if
it's like Burger King yeah I can expect
English I mean like you know what
happens is like late night they usually
hire people that are you know like fresh
from the board or whatever but their
English is really broken but they can
still speak English so then like
sometimes it's harder and you have to
place your aides and stuff but they get
it and they try they make an effort this
is just crazy that nobody there speaks
English yeah because usually there's
like a STONER there working that can
help out the the you know not even
pictures on the man and then like also
like but like just read the menu like
even if the menu was written in Spanish
since it's the mostly spanish-speaking
neighborhood like I mean like you could
pronounce stuff in English and it would
sound really [ __ ] bad but you would
still probably know like what they're
saying you know I but sure the following
or if you pulled up images on the phone
like Clark's rap supreme or something
right I can we can even translate go on
google chance yeah that's just no effort
yeah I mean I'll be real though if I was
the lady and like working at Taco Bell
and you want to come at me being rude
like that and then you put a camera in
your face no I was being there's anymore
like I like like I mean part of is just
like don't be disrespectful I'm 50/50 on
it although I would think she was
disrespecting super rude like from the
job and like you're right the video came
in half way and so like and also while
she was telling her I don't speak
English she was actually being nice like
she wasn't trying to compromise but she
was being nice while doing it and she
was like this person's disrespectful I'm
not gonna serve them thank you goodbye
you know you know how it feels like to
be hangry at 10:30 she wasn't herself I
I think she would have got I think she
would have done better if like I mean I
guess if she really can't really speak
English she can't tell her like I'm not
gonna serve you because you're being
disrespectful
she used not speaking English as her
excuse and then therefore it made it
like no I wonder if the person in the
car behind them spoke Spanish or English
oh they could have helped
yeah she's basically came out and helped
or if they don't speak Spanish they're
like this [ __ ] is lying she just took
i order happens to me quite often we're
like whether it's like someone at the
checkout line and they're Asian and they
can't speak English and then like the
cashier would look at me for help I
can't speak Korean or like will be I
like will be like flying somewhere and
they'll be like Asian grandma that
doesn't know how to turn off their phone
and they're like Jack deal with the with
the with the flight attendant and
they're looking at me like I'm like I
can't help you I don't know what to do
I'll be the same way like [ __ ] can you
do it no I don't know but yeah I'm
always like I get into those weird
situations you know it's pretty hard
these days like it post mates around our
area we get a lot of mainland Chinese
post mates and they barely know how to
use the app and they barely know how to
get into like our gate and all that
stuff and then sometimes they like the
end of calling me and I don't know why
they called me cuz they can't even speak
English and I have to kind of hear from
their broken ass English and I'm like oh
this guy speaks Chinese and I'll try to
speak to Chinese too I'll speak Chinese
them and then though the all thank God
all the guy was having a [ __ ] heart
after this GPS is routed me all day over
here I don't understand these [ __ ]
streets and I'm like damn imagine like
if they were delivering to a non Chinese
person they were just having a really
really hard time I have a lot of times
when I take words cuz I got home drive
so I think it was like two three four
times a day sometimes and like I've had
people that don't speak English at all
and like that sucks when I'm in their
car and like they don't know they don't
know how to like get like if you know if
there's like an issue or something yeah
like sometimes the GPS messes up and
I'll like have to like say like you know
like like huh I feel like growing up
here though in dealing with so many like
non-english speakers I just got so used
to using other forms of communication
we're like like some people they'll just
hear an accent they'll be like oh my god
I don't know how to [ __ ] deal with
this person and they get all frustrated
I'll just be like [ __ ] there's multiple
ways that you can do you can I remember
there was one time I was in I was I was
I was trying to communicate with this
lady and I think basically
she spoke we both spoke Japanese we were
overseas but then she's not Japanese she
was like Korean or Chinese or something
Oh interest yes so so we used Japanese
as a way to communicate but we were in a
different country like and I forgot for
what reason but I was like oh [ __ ] it
was it was it was really helpful that
that works is it not a requirement to
speak English at a u.s. job okay that's
a law right oh yeah but I mean also
that's why I suppose the franchise
because that manager will set the rules
and nobody's really looking over them
but I think for the most part I think
that human beings like we can community
can communicate without language
language is just a way for us to say
exactly how we feel or what we lutely do
we could talk to animals
yeah like kind of yeah like a lot of its
like gestures facial expressions plain
pointing you know like you can
communicate it took this a screenwriting
class by his guy named Robert McKee he's
like a really famous dude and he was
saying in a movie that is wit really
well acted and well-directed you should
be able to understand even if it's a
foreign film without so without the
subtitles because just through the
mannerisms you should build a tell is
this an angry scene who's who's like
where's the power struggle like what the
conflict is and and through all that so
you should be able to watch a form film
with no subtitles and have pretty much
an understanding like 80% if it's a
well-directed will active movie that's
never seen kdrama but do you think maybe
that's why that's so popular for non
Korean speaking but I got that sometimes
because I know there's there's one
co-worker lady nice to have and she
didn't understand any Korean she didn't
have the subtitles nothing but she would
watch it religiously as she knew
everything that was happening my mom was
like that as probably this point so
primal like you know what's happening
yeah my mom watched Korean dramas and
she didn't know what the hell they were
saying but she like was she's all into
it and I'm like they are really popular
after you said that I was just imagining
you know the movie the room I was
imagining taking all the dialogue away
and realizing I would have no
idea what the [ __ ] is going up with the
dialog like that's like such a good
example of like bad movie takeaway
dialogue because the acting was so poor
and like the scenes didn't establish
where that yeah that's that's five
minutes yeah but and it's like I don't
even know if they like each other
[Music]